hi this is dr. Berg in this video I want
to talk about weird in unexplainable
symptoms a lot of people go to the
doctor with symptoms and there's really
no test that they can pick up a lot of
these symptoms and I want to talk about
there's a part of the body called the
autonomic nervous system and this system
runs an automatic it's the system behind
all of their systems it controls
something called homeostasis which is
you your body's ability to adapt to this
environment okay so it's constantly
adjusting digestion even hormones a
temperature fluids valves in the body so
let's just kind of go through all the
symptoms some of the symptoms that could
occur if you have a problem with the
autonomic nervous system dysfunction
urinary problems urinary frequency and
count and incontinence all these
problems with the bladder because the
autonomic nervous system controls the
valves the valve of the eye so if you
actually put some light into the eye in
the mirror and you see your that little
black part go down like this it should
contract or constrict that's controlled
by the autonomic nervous system if you
have a weak autonomic nervous system
that contraction will won't be able to
hold for 20 seconds it starts going it's
weak it cannot hold the constriction so
that's a valve problem next one can't
sweat you exercise but you don't sweat
that's the autonomic nervous system
dysfunction sensitivity with sound or
light ringing the ears coughing at night
fainting especially maybe getting up too
fast and then passing out or feeling
light-headed that's the problem with
this too irregular heart rhythm
temperature issues let's say you feel
always hot or always cold see if you go
to a new chronologist and they test and
your thyroid is normal well it could be
this right here low blood pressure or
high blood pressure pots which is when
you stand up from lying down your pulse
rate can go too high or eve sometimes it
goes too low based on a little bit of
stress on your body dry eyes sweating
easily
see you get on the shower and you just
break on the sweat or your palms are
sweaty boom
premature ejaculation sleep disorders
all sorts of digestive problems with a
the food doesn't digest or you get
constipation and the next day you get
diarrhea epilepsy these are all symptoms
that a lot of people have and they go to
the endocrinologist to go to the immune
doctor they go to the GP and they don't
find it the expert of the autonomic
nervous system would be the neurologist
neurologist is an MD that studies the
autonomic nervous system and there's
dirt and tests that you can do to to
learn about this one of the first two
symptoms to know that this is breaking
down is one you stand up too fast you
get dizzy and number two you start
having bladder problems at night okay
those are the first two but there's a
lot of other things that can go wrong I
even have a test that measures the
autonomic nervous system using a
technology called heart rate variability
HRV testing I don't use it to diagnose
any diseases I use it mainly for stress
testing and to pick up the strength of
this system because I also specialize in
the nervous system but I don't treat
these conditions I do improve this
condition but I don't treat the symptom
this autonomic nervous system is is
really three parts one is the flight or
fight mechanism which is sympathetic and
then the other system that's the stress
reaction and any of the parasympathetic
which is the recovery of the stress and
then the last system is called enteric
which is all about your digestion and
those are the three systems and part of
the system is embedded inside your
adrenal it's also in your mid-back and
it's up in the back of the neck so it's
all over the place and it helps you
regulate a lot of body functions so if
you have these weird symptoms just
realize it could be a problem with that
system and you can kind of investigate
it more fairly yourself